it's time for me to throw to joe douglas
jets general manager yesterday first
talking about his quarterback third
overall pick in the 2018 draft sam
darnold here's douglas
i think you see
you see the flashes
of of what he can be and they're really
special
um
let's not forget that sam's a 23
year old quarterback that is maybe one
of the toughest quarterbacks i've ever
been around so um no i'm i'm very
excited about seeing
you know then then going off of going
off of that and believing that if you
surround him with more talent you know
he can he can be a top tier quarterback
and ultra talented i think is what she
said
why not commit to him definitively as
your quarterback in in 2021
well i'm no problem saying that he's
he's he is our best quarterback in our
quarterback for the future
well there it is sam darnold now not not
that any of it's binding right they can
change their mind if they want to i'm
not sure but yeah right
yeah i mean i look it's it's
we've heard stuff like this before you
got to get through the season you're
trying to get a win you don't want to
say well we really don't know about sam
darnold for next year that's not the way
to try to coax a win out of sam darnold
but when next year rolls around you can
make a different decision also you don't
want to tip your hand you don't want to
prejudice your ability to maybe trade
him to someone you know you always want
to be able to say we want to keep him so
i don't necessarily buy it look he
hasn't been anything close to the guy
that we thought he was going to be it
just seems like yesterday that three
years ago he was regarded as the top
prospect in the 2018 draft even though
you continuously pronounced his name
darno do you remember those days yes yes
you eventually figured out it's darnold
and we eventually figured out that uh
you know
he's not the best where would you put
them among the the first rounders we
know lamar jackson's one and we know
josh rosen's five right where do the
other three fall right now josh allen's
two for sure right yeah i mean that's
for sure and then it becomes between
baker and sam and
so who is it it's it is tough i'm not
gonna lie i
man
i'll give baker the edge right now but
it's not by a lot it's not and i'm not
so sure it's not just because he's got a
little more talent around him just to
show a little bit more of his talent now
yes sam darnold was
always in my opinion over
oh you know what i want to say
overdrafted over publicized he had a few
big games on national tv especially
being the penn state game and the rose
bowl and everybody just went oh he's the
greatest thing since sliced bread i mean
penn state couldn't play defense but and
then he became some people's highest
rated quarterback i've ever seen in the
history of the nfl draft and then he had
a pro day and he threw the ball and it
was raining and people were going it was
like the movie the natural i mean it's
amazing what he was doing he he could
throw in the rain so he was very
overhyped by that and that didn't help
him to where he came to new york and
people thought he was going to be able
to carry the football team and no he's
not he's not that type of talent he is
the type of talent that can be a
franchise quarterback though regardless
of what's happened the jets made the
cardinal sin of one hiring a horrible
xgm and then he made a horrible
you know decisions i should say because
he wasn't a good gm
that
he didn't give the guy any talent he
gave him no hope
zero hope
i you know again we could talk about
this all the time but i don't care who
you are patrick mahomes got to go into
travis kelsey and tyree kill and all
these other weapons and everything like
that you know you need something there
and i'll be interested to see what they
do with the jets because it's like sam
darnold i think they can win with him
going into the future
he's not trevor lawrence though i can
say that i you know i haven't studied
trevor lawrence that way yet but i've
seen enough of him to go
he is clearly the best quarterback and
he has clearly
got potential to be
a big time superstar in the nfl and
that's where the jets are going to have
to a lot of thinking to do if they
continue on this path here
and you mentioned their ex gm mike
mcagnan look he had that job longer than
he should have i like mike nice guy met
him talked to him but when you look at
the decisions that were made miss after
miss after miss christian hackenberg
what
what that was hey that was one of the
reasons why they didn't evaluate and
draft patrick mahomes i never had their
franchise quarterbacking christian
hackenberg where's he right now what has
he ever done did he ever even play in
the nfl other than in the preseason i
don't think he did no and and no and no
no i mean that was washed out of the aaf
that's one of the worst picks in the
history of football that really is and
listen we could talk about mike mckagan
and all that to me that still goes back
to ownership of the jets the ownership
for the jets stinks there's no other way
to say it all right i'm sorry i'm gonna
say it and the process they went about
to hire mike mccagnin is the dumbest
damn thing in the world so that's stop
hiring consultants right stop hiring
consultants because what they're going
to do is they're going to tell you to
hire their friend their protege their
family member right you hire mike
mccagnin who is charlie castle he's
right-hand man at one point in houston
so now castle is still in the game
casually can call mike mckagne and you
know feel like he's got some juice and
feel like he's got some influence and
maybe he shouldn't have any influence if
mike mccagnin is the guy he recommended
i don't know why these owners do it i
know why they do it chris because a lot
of them don't know what the hell else to
do exactly and they don't know where to
turn and they don't know who to ask
because their ego prevents them from
asking one of the other owners for
advice yes no or
or yeah they don't want to hear advice
from a smart football person because
they don't like the advice they're gonna
get they've already got themselves in
this little room of their own thoughts
and oh this is what i think and i don't
care and so then they hire other people
that just tell them that kind of crap
hey i mean it's it's an issue hey we
could talk about the team across town
from the jets you know they listen to
ernie of coursey with dave gettleman and
all that type of thing too the same type
of crap where i just want to go why
why are we asking guys who are
out of the game and not really in touch
anymore
to be the one to recommend who should
run your football team that makes it
beyond that no sense beyond that what
what you're getting you're not getting
an unbiased
scientific recommendation you're tapping
into the network of cronies and friends
and avoiding any enemies even if there's
some guy out there that would be the
perfect gm if the consultant doesn't
like that guy and wants to settle some
score from 15 years ago he's not getting
recommended for the job so that you know
you're it's a human being it's not some
repository of football excellence that's
going to spit out the right name it's a
human being that's going to have the
same biases and prejudices as anyone
else and you get you get what you pay
for in that situation all right joe
douglas also addressed
adam gase and his status and some
believe after monday night's game if
they lose to the patriots he'll be fired
here's douglas talking about his current
head coach
i'm going to say this this is this is
not all on adam you know um again i have
to do a better job of surrounding
surrounding um him with with uh better
players and better weapons you know
we're um we're in this together i'm i'm
going through and thinking of everything
i can do to try to try to help sam or
help adam and you know
the goal is to
get this fixed together so you're saying
he's part of the solution then
yes
[Music]
that last answer i wonder what he was
looking for off camera well he's looking
at notecard he's looking at notecards of
all these answers he's got reminders
there it looks like to me but i think i
think he was looking for the closest
exit and or to make sure that if he said
yes christopher johnson wasn't standing
there with a big hammer
right uh is it okay can i say yes okay
it's yes and look here's the reality
when
michael cagnum was fired after the 28
joe douglas was the first name mentioned
because that was the perception that it
would be adam gases hand-picked guy so
this isn't the traditional
gm coach relationship these two guys are
closer to being like this with maybe a
little bit of gas you know we've lost
sight of that over the last year and a
half right so to the extent that there's
this belief they're going to throw gase
out and joe douglas is going to get to
hire someone else
maybe they maybe they just press the
hard reset button you know and here's
the other dynamic to consider depending
upon the outcome of the election
and we don't know what it's going to be
but if the guy who appointed woody
johnson to be the u.s ambassador to the
uk loses woody's coming back here's the
thing though
will would he be back by early january
when the hiring season typically starts
or will he be back more like
april may june when it's too late to
really do anything
you know there's a chance that the
status quo was going to hold for the
jets that christopher johnson is going
to understand exactly where they are why
they are how they got there why they got
there and why they need to not start
over again
because nothing good is going to come
from starting over again unless they
would get the trevor lawrence pick and
then use trevor lawrence and the
opportunity to get trevor lawrence as
the centerpiece for moving forward with
a coach that
that that would that would want to and
crave the opportunity to coach trevor
lawrence no yeah yeah i mean it
i'm with you i don't think it's like
just a slam dunk gases out of there
but i will say just up here in the new
york area and things like that
i you know again i think the jets are
going to have a hard time not
kind of folding to the public pressure
when it comes to adam gase i do i just
and again a guy that i'll sit here and
say a lot of the same things i just said
about sam darnold i mean what does
people expect he was left a pile of crap
from mike mc cagnan and everything like
that
joe douglas did some good things this
offseason you know and some of the
things that i think he thought might
work out some of these under the radar
value type free agent signings maybe
didn't work out quite as well as he had
hoped certainly you know but you can't
blame this all on adam gase but
unfortunately as you and i both know
perception starts to become reality and
up here in new york
i just think everybody has already
chalked it up they've already chalked it
up and that's the fight that gates and
the jets would have to deal with if they
stayed status quo and that to me
ultimately i think is where they will
bend and break
and
ultimately fire adam gase just because i
think the public and the fans here just
won't take anything else other than that
yeah i think that a lot of pr work would
have to be done to turn this around and
it's not nearly enough for joe
douglas to say i failed to give adam
gase enough pieces right because really
joe douglas is being diplomatic here he
hasn't been there long enough to give
him enough pieces it's the prior guy's
pile of crap that both douglas and gays
are now
trying to scrape off of their shoes as
they try to remain employed apologize
for the graphic example as you're
enjoying your breakfast
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports